we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
question that i'm going to assume is
being asked in good faith but it hasn't
been answered so many times take a
listen i david my name is luigi would
you kindly address the tax increase that
would probably happen if Sanders or
Warren instituted their Medicare for all
bill probably worded that and correctly
but you know what I mean
yeah listen so Elizabeth Warren doesn't
have a medicare for all bill she said
she likes Bernie's but she's open to
other ideas we don't know exactly how
her plan would be funded although she
has said total costs would go down the
rich and corporations would pay more
okay let's focus on Bernie's Bernie has
addressed the costs and I've addressed
the costs your total cost would go down
under Medicare for all there would be a
payroll tax that is added it would be a
couple percentage points to the average
worker corporations would pay a piece of
it as well premiums go away co-pays go
away
coinsurance goes away all of these costs
go down and then you pay a little bit
through your payroll tax if you can't
afford it if you don't have a job that's
okay the numbers account for that
already this has been addressed the
there is a fair criticism that Bernie is
not always the most solid in terms of
his messaging of how this will work it's
been addressed the proposal to pay for
it is out there and I'm not criticizing
the caller but lots of people just
haven't seen that to continue to pretend
as some are doing that the cost element
hasn't been addressed or that the tax
element hasn't been dealt with it has
now you might not like it you might
disagree with the approach you could
disagree that the numbers have been
calculated correctly reasonable people
can disagree about whether the cost of
the program has been properly assessed
that's all very reasonable but to
pretend that Bernie hasn't addressed
this time and time again he has and it's
widely available online and I encourage
you to check it out we've got a great
bonus show for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at join Pakman doc
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show